hello everyone and welcome to the most
important Tournament of January it is
the Tata still Masters and we have a
wonderful game between gookish and the
dingler and uh with a wonderful
tournament some very very strong players
strong names here like two 2800 players
the only 220 800 players in the world
today Magnus Crossing and Dean lyren uh
and uh some uh very strong upcoming
stars like uh like Lookers like pregnant
and Vincent kymer of Arjun Erica is they
will be doing their best of course to
try and take a few points uh from these
absolute monsters and this game is
really stunning I hope you guys will
enjoy it uh let's check it out and then
we're going to discuss a little bit
about the tournament so gookish with the
white pieces opens with a Ponte D4 and
yes this is ding's first tournament
after the candidates tournament after
qualifying um to play for the title of
world chess champion uh not directly but
as Magnus decided not to play and apple
is the actual Challenger ding was a can
best in the candidates that's why Dean
will be playing against Nepal for the
title of world chess champion so let's
see uh how how he does D4 we have Knight
to F6 C4 E6 Knight to F3 going for the
anti-nimzo Indian uh we have B6 ding
goes for the Queen's Indian defense
something that we often say that ever
since those Alpha zero games it seems
like black really shouldn't play this
because Alpha zero just completely
obliterated stockfish when stockfish
played the Queen's Indian uh the problem
is uh humans aren't able to play these
positions quite at the level of alpha
zero so it's still okay for humans to go
for the Queen's Indian G3 we have Bishop
Ace Bishop to B7 uh still the the most
preferred move but uh Bishop to A6 I
think is played at the at the top level
so B3 also forces white to deal with the
hanging C4 Pawn with Bishop to B for
with check Bishop to D2 and now Bishop
back to E7 so black plays twice with the
dark Square special but white will also
have to do it at some point as you don't
really want your bishop and D2 so Bishop
to G2 we have castles castles and now
Pawn to D5 biting this is all very well
known Theory nothing you'll hear Knight
to C3 C6 and now Bishop to F4 sometimes
C characters and D5 is played Bishop
therefore is the other uh top move
Knight beat the D7 and now C captures on
D5 and here uh some games have reached
this position I think five of them in
the database from Top tier tournaments
where C characters on D5 was played and
even though the engine says you should
play Knight captures on D5 no one plays
that ever e captures and D5 by Ding and
it is now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game so the difference is
now the E file is semi-open for black
and the C file is closed usually would
have an open C file and both white and
black would put the Rooks on the C file
but now ding has this backwards C6 pawn
and uh it's very interesting to see what
he will do with this and how how he will
push this game forward so of course uh
gookers goes for Knights the E1 he wants
to put the Knight on D3 where he will
also have control over E5 but also over
the C5 Square so rooked E8 we have
Knight to D3 and now Knight the f8 going
after the bishop here Knight to E6 will
force black to either move really back
with the bishop or to just trade it so
Google decides to trade it right away
Bishop G5 Knight to E6 and here we have
a trade Bishop captures Bishop captures
now ding has the bishop pair and uh
we'll see if he is able to do something
with it we have Pawn to E3 opening up
this diagonal but it should not be a
problem
uh but that that's just it it should not
but it kind of is uh because ding plays
the absolutely tricky Knight to C5 and
uh he's not sacrificing a piece or
anything if you capture the Knight on C3
will hang but if you don't capture how
are you dealing with the Knight on D3
which kind of makes E3 a problem it's
not a problem if you play Perfect chess
but that is easier said than done so you
have to capture the Knight there's
nothing you can do about it the the
there's no way to add an extra Defender
to the Knight on D3 so D captures in C5
Bishop captures in C3 Rook to C1 you
have to save the rook and now Queen to
F6 ding develops the queen connects the
Rooks and the defenses bishop and C3
Queen C2 uh you don't have to worry
about a move like the uh B captures on
C5 now because the bishop and C3 is
hanging so ding has to deal with that
first and now ding plays D4 and now the
problem is if you play e characters on
D4 and Bishop captures look at ding's
Bishop pair now you do not want to play
against this you can can't move the
Knight because the Rook hangs you can't
move the Rook then you weaken the F2
Pawn too much if you move the Knight
also Rook is coming to E2 so it will be
incredibly difficult for for Google to
stop this bishop pair uh he plays uh
instead after D4 of course he plays C
captures
um uh on B6 we have eight characters on
B6 biting and now Rook after D1 and now
you might expect Rook 8 to C8 to add
more support to this C6 Pawn uh but
didn't just plays Rook to d8 he says
this will not be an issue and okay e
captures on D4 Bishop captures on D4 and
now what's the idea behind the hanging
C6 Pawn King Lucas captured let's check
out Queen captures on C6 that loses
fairly quickly because now just Bishop
captures and D3 and it doesn't matter if
you trade queens or not if you play
Queen captures and F6 then just Bishop
captures on F6 and the bishop is now
defended you're down a full piece so
what you could play is Rook captures on
D3 but that also doesn't help because
now Queen captures an F to check and you
get checkmate it Rook the D1 a rook D1
chakra captures Queen captures and once
the bishop blocks uh it will be Queen to
F1 Checkmate so the queen cannot capture
and C6 one thing Lucas could do is play
Bishop captures in C6 and it is in fact
the strongest move but uh voluntarily
put your Bishop on C6 and run into Rook
to C8 it just doesn't look like a very
human move I will show it because it's a
classical game which should show nice
lines uh now the the thing is now you
have to find Knight to F4 it adds uh
additional support to this F2 pawn and
you don't have to worry about G5 because
Knight to H5 will come with an attack on
the queen so here you will see something
like Bishop captures on F2 Queen
captures an F2 now Rook captures on C6
and now Knight to D5 white has to play
this in order to trade as many pieces as
possible now you either trade queens or
you don't and then look at this just
Rook captures on C6 Queen captures and
queen capture address and B6 absolutely
spectacular Queen to A8 and now Knights
the E7 check even if row captures then
Rook turn d8 will win the black queen so
you're gonna have to play King to f8 now
the Knight will move and you have this
position let's say uh where the material
is almost equal uh a bookish would be up
up a pawn but I mean it's hard to say if
you will be able to survive with your
king wide in the open like this uh so
okay it's a possibility but you really
have to you really have to calculate
everything so here gookers goes for
Knight to the F4 first it makes sense
you really don't want your F2 Pawn
hanging all the time now ding plays Pawn
to G5 but now it's a little bit
different because now after Knights the
H5 Queen to H6 attacks the Knight and
now there are all sorts of problems uh
the the Knight is hanging uh also Rook
to E2 is coming if Rook to E2 lens then
the F2 Pawn will will uh be just weak so
here Bishop to F3 uh the only good move
for uh gookers defending the Knight also
guarding that E2 square but now Pawn to
C5 in the this is how ding solves the
problem of the all of the of the C6 pawn
it took him a while uh some 25 moves but
now once it's on C5 look at this the
bishop and pawn here uh really uh
controlled the two Rooks and the two
Rooks really have no business being on
C1 and D1 as long as ding has this Pawn
on C5 and Bishop and D4 here bookish
plays G4 okay now the Knight is defended
you don't have to worry about that so
you can move the bishop but now ding has
an absolutely spectacular move uh which
you guys are welcome to try and find uh
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this idea while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh are always
trying to open new lines for Attack on
your opponent's king and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Pawn to F5 such a such a brutal move
to see on the board the ding of course
played it and now the problem is you
can't really capture this look at this
if if Queen captures an F5 then there's
Bishop to C8 and now where do you where
do you move the queen uh you you can't
really go anywhere you can play C2 or B1
let's say queen to C2 but now ding has
the semi-open f file as well he's just
gonna play Rook to f8 attack the bishop
and then the F2 Pawn will become weak
then he's gonna pile up under that file
Rooks coming to F7 with more pressure
then the queen will come to help and you
will not be able to to withstand this so
after F5 bookish plays Knight the G3 he
goes after the F5 Pawn this way but now
ding just plays F captures on G4 and now
the problem is if you capture with the
bishop then ding shifts the bishop to
this diagonal and now once you say
goodbye to this diagonal well I mean if
you just look at the lines black is
controlling you you don't even have to
calculate this position so this is I
mean they're too scary to even look at
so after this F characters on G4 we have
Knight to F5 going after the queen and
the bishop here but now Queen to F6 and
it seems like could capture on D4 and
maybe alleviate the pressure a little
bit but if Knight captures on D4 then G
captures on F3 and again you have
problems that cannot be solved how are
you stopping Checkmate here you can play
Queen to F5 okay this offers a queen
trade but now Rook D6 and after Queen
captures Rook captures the F3 Pawn is
still defended let's say Knight to C2
you're gonna play something like rookie
4 then Advance the pawns and then the
king and then it will be again the
bishop is much stronger than knight uh
you're up upon ding would would win this
position so after Queen F6 Bishop to E4
very strong move by gukesh putting
pressure on the H7 Pawn as well uh ding
plays H5 of course he needs to advance
those pawns to attack the uh the the
black king because the white king
because with these Bishops here once H4
and G3 lands that's it you will not be
able to play F characters on G3 you
don't you don't have to calculate the to
see that this is crushing so bookish
finds the absolute best move he plays
Pawn to B4 as it often is the the
absolute best move uh King a fade by
ding he wants to get the king away from
any and all checks like he wants to get
away from this check he wants to get
away from this check he wants to get
away from potential Knight checks so
King to f8 eliminates uh any check that
white had in mind in the foreseeable
future and now uh gookish has a chance
to maybe maybe defend this position but
uh it would be silly to even ask you to
find the move here so I'm not gonna I'm
just gonna show you what uh glucose
played A3 here and it's almost the
correct move he he has to play A4 here
but it's uh impossible to understand why
the point is after Dean continues with
H4 now you can play B5 that's the point
and now okay you can't go here the dash
of controls B7 you have to play Bishop
here now Knight captures on d4c
characters and pawn to A5 look at this
now you are threading a6a7 so B captures
an A5 Now Pawn to B6 you sacrifice this
Pawn as well otherwise B7 is coming and
after Queen captures on B6 there's a
bishop C6 blocking the black queen from
uh helping out with the defense Queen is
coming to F uh not to F5 but you can
bring the uh Queen anywhere you want and
then you will at least have some sort of
a Perpetual uh maybe even Checkmate to
show you uh how how maybe this could
play out let's say D3 okay you have to
find some wizard moves here Queen to C3
goes after the black king Rook to E6 now
also stops the queen to F6 and now Queen
to h8 with check King F7 Queen H7 trick
King F6 Bishop to E4 now again with all
sorts of nasty ideas like
Queen G7 Checkmate so D2 Rook the C7 now
threatening Checkmate and now Bishop D7
blocking and it's a I mean look at this
position uh it seems like uh anything is
possible but uh White would actually
have to settle for a Perpetual here with
King E7 and queen G7 check King 8 Queen
G8 and now we will have a nice Perpetual
here so absolutely crazy stuff here I
mean that it's impossible that it would
play out this way but I just want to
show you what uh the position uh hides
or the secrets that are that are hidden
in the position but okay Google played
A3 and the problem is this does not come
with any threat and now ding is free to
play H4 and now G3 is pretty much
Unstoppable Rook D1 uh is what Google's
played and now feel free to pause the
video and uh find the the finishing blow
for ding while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always finding
incredible ways of breaking through uh
your opponent's defenses and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook captures on e4 uh not and now
once you see what uh what book has
played now you will realize why Rook
characters on e4 is so powerful uh book
has played Queen captures on e4 but
let's discuss Rook captures on e4 it
seems also possible because now if Queen
captures Rook you can just deliver a
check and pick up the black queen uh the
problem is there is Bishop to D3 look at
this spectacular idea by Ding and now
you really don't have a move uh once you
play Queen captures on D3 just Bishop
captures and F2 and now it's white
actually who loses the queen king
captures Rook captures and you cannot
defend the Knight so you will lose the
Knight as well uh so it's Queen and Rook
against rook and Rook of completely
crushing so Google played Queen captures
an E4 instead but the death does not
save him from ding's idea Bishop to D3
Works once again and now now Queen to E6
okay you offer a queen trade but now
ding is very happy as he will have the
mighty Bishop pair for Rook so Queen
captures an E6 Rook captures and now
just Bishop captures on F5 absolutely
incredible now the two Bishops will
fight against the rook and uh well you
you just can't save this Rogue captures
on B6 is played this does create a past
Pawn for for bookish but the ding just
goes for the kill Pawn to G3 H
characters H captors you cannot save
this uh B captures and C5 was played but
now just Bishop to H3 and he was in this
position on move 39 uh before reaching
time control that agukish resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here let me just check uh I don't want
to trick you guys maybe he uh uh I mean
it's uh not very likely but maybe he did
lose some time no no okay he he still
had two minutes on the clock uh when the
game ended I thought maybe because it's
a move 39 maybe because they didn't
reach time control that he may be lost
on time but no uh he he just resigned
here here the problem is uh black can
just move pieces like you like a cat
could move pieces for black and you
would still win this because every move
wins let's say Rook to C2 you want to
add a Defender now rookie a threatening
Checkmate and now after Rook to B1 uh
defending Checkmate you could just play
G4 this is very important because you
have to play G captures and F2 and then
attacked attack the pinned piece once
again and now after let's say C6 you're
gonna play King to G7 You're Gonna Play
C7 G captures and F2 check real
characters and now you will attack the
pinned Rook once again King H2 G
captures on F2 and that's it nothing
more to be done here A4 you're gonna
play Rook to E1 with check and of course
now uh the white king will get
checkmated King H2 Bishop to E5 with
check King captures and H3 and queen to
G3 one of the possible continuations but
like I said any anything wins here for
black and of course that's why Google
should resigned uh so there you have it
if you were wondering if ding is ready
for the World Chess Championship Match
uh well uh if we consider what happened
in round one against a spectacular
player like gookish with the white
pieces I would say the ding is ready but
still uh World Series Championship is a
different story and nepo is a different
kind of Beast that we'll see we'll see
what happens there for now we are
focusing on the Tata still incredible
game by both of them but it seems that
Ding uh absolutely out prepared gulkash
this e-capters and D5 move that was
never played before uh obviously proved
too much for for Lucas and even though
he defended well uh already when the
just a few moves later ding found this
Knight the E5 Knight the C5 move which
uh won him the bishop pair and it was
just
he already had the bishop pair but it
made the bishop pair more powerful so I
mean absolutely incredible game and
Masterpiece if you will uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
that first game that we've covered from
the Masters hope more games are are uh
this incredible uh we'll see what
happens uh I would like to thank a
randomfile.net the Jimbo Robert Kiefer
deutron and ravishing reptiles YouTube
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the Tata steel and Masters
and Challengers until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day